Natasha: What’d you get for question #2?
Cause I think it’s-
Hanson, could you stay awake and at least
pretend like you’re trying to pass
tomorrow’s test?
Hanson: Dunno, ask Derek?
Derek?
Derek: Depression?
What even is depression-
Natasha: Depression, major depressive disorder,
or clinical depression, is a mood
disorder that causes a prolonged feeling of
sadness affecting more than 264 million
people worldwide.
Natasha: It is associated with decreased activity
of serotonin, a neurotransmitter in the
central nervous system responsible for feelings
of happiness.
Hanson: When the presynaptic cell receives
stimulus and transfers an impulse - (action
potential) - down the neuron's axon, membrane
vesicles containing neurotransmitters
release serotonin.
Derek: Serotonin travels through the synaptic
cleft and binds to 5-HT receptors on the
spines of postsynaptic neurons, which depolarizes
them, allowing for the rapid
continuation of impulses that induce feelings
of happiness.
After being released,
neurotransmitters are absorbed into the presynaptic
neuron where they are either reused
or decomposed.
Derek: Depression disrupts this process, preventing
the generation of "happy feelings."
Hanson: SSRI (Selective serotonin reuptake
inhibitors) are drugs that block the serotonin
transporter causing serotonin to be in the
synaptic cleft for longer periods of time,
additionally stimulating the 5-HT receptors
and restoring serotonin levels during action
potentials to near-homeostatic standards,
allowing patients to feel “normal” again,
for the
duration of the drug.
Derek: Depression is damaging and associated
with emotional distancing and
dysfunctional peer and family relationships.
Drug and alcohol abuse may be used to cope,
leading to life-long consequences.
Derek: Tragically, due to its association
with suicide, depression can also be fatal.
Hanson: Screening for depression, whether
from a written PHQ-9 test or a
psychiatrist-conducted psychological exam,
is important as a professional diagnosis
increases a patient’s access to rehabilitative
resources and the chance of recovery.
Natasha: Despite its severity, there is still
a negative societal stigma surrounding
depression, resulting in undermining and belittling
those who suffer from it.
Increasing
awareness may alleviate this stigma, improving
the wellbeing of students and citizens
worldwide.